Okay Michael, so
I have brought back yet another slide,
slightly modified, from the discussion
on options and constraints.
Do you recognize it, you remember this?
>> Well, it's got the Pac-Man thing
on it, and it has the four options or
whatever that we just talked about.
And it has the beginnings
of a stoplight.
>> Right, exactly right, so in fact I
told you a little about this experiment
that we did, where we asked people
to come up with these options.
But there was a second
part to the experiment.
There are two buttons,
this is me attempting to draw
what a button looks like.
There's a green button and
there's a red button.
And what you're being asked to do is
to watch Pac-Man over here run around
executing actions including
these options you came up with.
And then occasionally you're supposed
to hit a green or red button.
And what do you think that the green and
the red stand for?
>> Probably green is Pac-Man
did something good, and
the red is the Pac-Man did
something not so good.
>> Right, that's exactly right.
So this is supposed to mean good.
And this is supposed to mean bad,
just like you would expect.
We had people do this, and they did it.
They would say that's good,
that's bad, that's bad, that's bad.
That's good, that's good, that's good,
that's good, that's good, that's good,
that's good, that's bad,
and so on and so forth.
Now, here's my question to you.
Given that people have done all of this,
and
they've given us lots of data on
whether Pac-Man did well or did poorly.
What would be the obvious thing
to do with that information?
>> The obvious thing would be,
it seems like the right thing.
Which is to,
if you treat the good as a plus one and
the bad as a minus one, and
have the agent just maximize for reward.
That should basically be
reinforcement learning.
>> Right, and
that makes a lot of sense, right?
So since we do reinforcement learning,
we'd want to turn this into
a reinforcement learning problem.
And we would say well,
every time you said something was good,
I'm going to treat that as a reward
of say one, it doesn't really matter.
And bad say is something like that,
and you get a reward for
say, being in a state in
taking a particular action.
And that's a perfectly
reasonable thing to do.
And in fact this ends up being a way
to get human beings to help us to
automatically do reward shaping.
And in fact you can show
this works pretty well.
And again,
there's been a lot of work on this,
we have provided some papers on this for
the students to read about.
And you do better, as you might imagine,
by treating these things as reward
shaping than if you didn't.
Because really they're hints,
as you move along,
about where you ought to be and
the kinds of things you have to do.
But remember what I said before,
that human beings actually
are trying to tell you something.
And they might be trying to tell you
something different from what you
want them to be.
So, if I think back to what you just
said, what you kind of said is,
well look it's a reinforcement
learning problem.
Reinforcement learning
problems need rewards, and so
we should convert these
things into rewards.
Well, it turns out that in practice,
when you actually talk to humans,
and work out what they do,
they're not actually doing this.
When they say good and they say bad,
they're not thinking in terms of
actual rewards, plus one, minus one.
Or plus ten and minus nine,
and these kinds of things.
Because of course they're not
reinforcement learning experts,
they're not thinking about rewards.
They're actually giving you
a different kind of information.
So here, let me just ask you.
If I told you in English,
that you should hit the green button
whenever the agent does something right.
And the red button when
the agent does something wrong,
then what kind of information am I
conveying, other than a reward value?
>> Well, one way to put it,
is your you're giving commentary
on the behavior or the policy.
>> That's exactly right,
that really in fact, it turns out,
you could convert these
things into rewards.
>> But you could also convert them into
something that's a bit more direct.
You can just say well you're
actually telling me that in this
particular state,
I should in fact take this action.
Or that in this particular state,
I should not take this action.
And this is direct policy advice,
as opposed to reward advice.
And so maybe, what we're really doing,
is not reward shaping, or
what humans are doing is not reward
shaping, it's actually a policy shaping.